I would say that if you're jasper
morrison you are you know you are an ear
tom dixon you are truly thinking about
how i can change the lives of every
person and how i can introduce something
fun and sharp and sensible and do a
London flat but how perhaps I can get
something into a big box retailer and
have it trickle down into the heartland
I truly think that there are certain
designers who think that way who think
that that they would like to improve on
the post-it note and they'd like to make
it you know and when moma included the
post-it note as part of their relaunch
of their design galleries after the
expansion of their space a couple years
ago you know they famously put a post-it
note on display and I never went and saw
it it's funny but everyone just kept
talking about like they've them mama put
a post-it out what's that worth I'm like
what supposed to cost you you know but
the point is is that it's it's about
improving everyday live lives um on the
other hand I absolutely feel that that
many many designers I think they're
thinking in the same way that furniture
craftsmen you know thought about they
want to create a beautiful piece maybe
it's bespoke maybe it's for their client
and you know the wealth or the client
the better their piece the more money
they can make you know that's and that's
so yeah hedge fund that kind of hedge
fund cliche in terms of these guys are
adding stuff that said for all of the
heat that my market has generated and
all the press that it has generated I
still feel that the value of what we're
selling is not growing exponentially the
way contemporary art does you know it is
one thing to say gosh in 1996 this table
is worth 10,000 and now it's worth 150
thousand and that does happen in our
market but it's it's still a huge
difference than from saying gosh i
bought this work of art from googan in
2002 for 150,000 and now is for
community
you